be sure to check out my second channel
called Rob explains there you can check
out videos where I explain things
outside of comic books so continuing our
discussion of comparing The Walking Dead
TV show to the comics following the
shooting of Carl by Otis where the TV
show saw this multi episode event
featuring Shane and Otis running to a
local high school that served as a FEMA
shelter during the outbreak in order to
locate a respirator extra surgical
supplies and medicine due to the fact
that the bullet had fragmented and hit
an artery in the comics this didn't
happen Hershel fixed up Carl right away
without any of all that stuff while
there was somewhat of a waiting game to
see if Carl would recover adequately I
would wager that the additive nt's to
the TV show served to provide an
increase in tension in addition to this
in the comic books
Herschel's family consisted of three
sons and four daughters his eldest son
was named Arnold followed by his
youngest named Billy and his four
daughters or Lacey as oldest Maggie his
second oldest as well as Rachael and
Susie
unlike the show Hershel does not have a
wife here and she's never mentioned so
we don't really know her fate
furthermore Herschel's group is also
composed of Otis and his wife Patricia
regarding Otis there are a couple of
differences in a couple of similarities
between the comic and the TV show in the
TV show
Otis was largely depicted as honorable
and hardworking while the comics depict
him is somewhat of a simpleton what I'd
also like to draw your attention to is
the fact that there is no character
named Beth Greene and the comics her
character was actually created
explicitly for the show another major
difference between the comics in the
show is the barn and the TV show the
barn was discovered by Glynn and served
as a vector for providing us with an
answer to what it was that had happened
to Sophia following her disappearance
and the comics the barn being used as a
storage place for zombies is actually
told to Rick by Hershel himself now
where the TV show saw Shane freaking out
and claiming that all the walkers in the
barn should be killed and Rick remain
clear-headed and tried to reason with
her shil and the comics Rick was
actually the person losing his mind and
claiming that all the zombies needed to
die however
Herschel's rationale for storing the
zombies and the barn is the same in both
the comics and the show and that he
believes that a time will come when
humanity will find a cure for the zombie
plague and when they do those who have
been infected will be returned to a
state of normalcy
this logic is fueled by the fact that in
the comics Herschel's second son Shawn a
person that we did not list in our
initial listing of his sons was bitten
and turned into a zombie now the
circumstance surrounding the zombies in
the barn and how the release is also
different here in the show Shane had
lost his mind in an effort to force
Hershel to face the fact that the
zombies couldn't be turned back but to
also take control of the group and the
comics a zombie had roamed onto the farm
and when Hershel tried to put it into
the barn the other zombies inside the
bar and began to pour out in the process
Herschel's eldest son arnold jumped in
to save him and was consumed by the
zombies and while the rest of the group
joins and killing the zombies
Herschel's oldest daughter lacy is
attacked as well resulting in her death
and so in the face of the fact that the
zombies are killing various members of
his family Hershel comes to the
realization that there is no bringing
him back and kills both his zombified
son Sean as well as Arnold after he
reanimates now in terms of the other
elements of the farm a lot of the things
remained relatively the same from the TV
show a Glenn and Maggie formal
relationship and Hershel actually walked
in on the two while they were together
and with the fall out of the group
killing all the zombies Herschel's
rationale is the same between the comics
and the show when Rick approaches him
with the issue of sleeping in the barn
and how it can't be viewed as a
long-term option
Herschel's response is that the group
can stay until Karl heals but after that
they have to leave this sentiment has
compounded on when laureate Hershel get
into an argument about the group having
to leave according to Lori the various
weapons provided or Hershel and his
group aided in their survival and if it
had not been for Rick's group Hershel
and his ilk would have most likely died
while the zombies broke free but in the
eyes of Hershel he took Rick's group in
provided medical treatment to their son
and in the process lost two of his own
now Rick tries to rationalize with
Hershel by stating that they had
believed that he was allowing them to
stay permanently but with Lori having
previously informed him of their
pregnancy and when supply scarce be on
the farm the group is almost guaranteed
to die whether by zombies starvation or
any number of other causes however for
all of his talk Hershel refuses to
accept for exploit and after pulling a
gun on him
Rick accepts Herschel's demands and
agrees to leave now this circumstance as
is presented runs on direct contrast
to the TV show which saw Rick's group
vacate the farm after it was overrun by
a horde of zombies what I also want to
do here is have a discussion about Glen
with the rest of Rick's group leaving
after Hershel kicked them out Glen was
allowed to stay after Maggie had spoken
to Hershel now this is something I would
like you to remember because this will
become especially important for Glen's
character in the issues of 100 and 101
but with Rick's team heading back out on
the road there eventually comes a point
when they run out of gas instructing the
group to search for abandoned cars that
may have gasoline as well as some food
and supplies everyone begins to fan out
as something I'd also like to draw your
attention to is that Dale and Andrea
have begun a relationship with one
another while this is not the most
important thing in the world I thought
it was something worth mentioning if for
no other reason than to illustrate the
continuing differences between the show
and the comic but while Dale and Andrea
are hunting for supplies they eventually
stumble across the prison something to
reveal to Rick and the rest of the group
is the way the TV show continued you see
a rather large deviation from the source
material in the time on Herschel's form
during the era of the prison and once we
get to the section of the governor we're
gonna find that the differences begin to
increase even further in the TV show the
group had transitioned to the prison
almost immediately after the incident at
Hershel's farm which remained the
central location of the events
throughout season 3 and for the first
half of season 4 the following its
discovery like the comics everyone began
preparing the prison for occupation by
clearing out the yard along with one of
the cell blocks where things began to
deviate was with the inmates and the TV
show the inmates were led by a man named
Tomas with the group surviving the end
of the world after the guards had locked
them into the prison along with a
massive amount of food and supplies in
the comics the backstory of the inmates
was relatively the same except that a
man named Dexter led the group now in
the comics like the show the inmates and
Rick's group came into direct conflict
when the problem arose of who deserves
to live in the prison where Rick and his
group had cleared up the zombies and
viewed the prison as their own the
inmates argued that they had been there
the entire time now the big difference
between the show and the comics is that
in the TV show Tomas had tried to kill
Rick after which he responded by killing
Tomas and the conex Rick struck first as
an undercurrent to the events leading
from the departure in Atlanta up to the
prison various members of the group were
to question Rick's leadership one of the
members in particular the wife of Otis
named Patricia had retrieved weapons
from the armory in a block intending to
launch an insurgency by having Rick
killed Patricia provided weapons to
Dexter who confronted Rick at gunpoint
and demanding that he and his ilk leave
Rick opens the door to a block and in
doing so releases a hoard of zombies
while Dexter initially works with Rick
to eliminate the zombie threat Rick
takes the opportunity to kill Dexter as
something else also want to talk about
here is the concept of the pneumonia
outbreak in the TV show and the comics
this never happened instead this seemed
to be a kind of substitute for the
murder of Herschel's daughters Rachael
and Susie as well as the death of
Teresa's daughter Julie and the conex
following rick's departure from
Hershel's farm and their discovery of
the prison one of the inmates housed
within the prison alongside dexter was a
man named thomas Richards as he was
initially presented thomas was quiet and
reserved and claimed to have been
arrested for tax evasion and however as
a story or the prison progressed and
rick began moving members of Herschel's
family to the prison as a safer location
Rachael and Susie were found decapitated
as a still returned at a kind of a
whodunit mystery it was eventually
revealed that the killer was Thomas when
he attempted to kill Andrea while she
was doing laundry after he was in prison
following this discovery one of the
members of Rick's group sought to
release him but as a consequence was
attacked by Thomas almost immediately
responding to the panic Maggie had
killed Thomas by shooting him to death
and so angry over the death of his
daughters Rachael and Susie the Hershel
had requested that Rick throw Thomas's
body over the fence and allow him to be
consumed by the zombies something that
Rick agreed to now regarding tyreese's
daughter Julie her death actually had
nothing to do with Thomas but was more
due to a romantic gesture gone wrong
when a gunshot rang out through the
prison
Rick jumps into action by grabbing his
gun and investigating but after arriving
at its source he finds Tyreese cradling
his daughter with her boyfriend Chris
cowering in the corner what we're told
is that the intention of Chris and Julie
was to live together forever and that
they intended to shoot each other at the
same time however Chris had pulled the
trigger before Julie could pull hers and
shot her before she could shoot him as a
result Rick simply leaves allowing
Tyreese to quite literally choke Chris
to death and after he reanimated brutal
his body chop them into pieces and burn
the remains with that being said we're
going to bring this video to an end and
in the next video what we're gonna do is
we're gonna focus more on the
relationship the various dichotomies
between Rick and Tyreese as well as the
circumstances that lead to the
introduction of the governor when that
being said I will catch you guys under
Cruz